hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to the
edition of ask Evan today might ring a
question from one of our YouTube viewers
I love you guys this is George Rowton to
say hey could you please tell me all
your google chrome extensions that you
use in the comments please so thanks
George for the question I love using
chrome I find it's really fast and easy
to use and a level the different
extensions that come along with it I
have some got to use at home and some
that I use at the office so I'm on my
office computer now so the extension is
a little bit different more for business
purposes so I'm going to do a quick
review of the ones I use here usually
the chrome extensions are up here on the
right top right to kind of see what
they're all about there's two that i use
always a lot a lot a lot and they save
me so much time and the other ones are
supplemental so the two that i love
absolutely the first is last pass this
is the last pass icon here and basically
what this does is allows me to log in to
any website that i have a password an
account with so from logging in to
youtube or from logging into my forms or
logging into Evernote or any third party
service that i use it automatically
remembers my password and logs me in for
me so i don't have to remember all of
those passwords that you have to create
four different sites it also will help
me create a new password so if i'm
launching a new if I'm talking up for a
new account on some website I don't want
to use the same password for everything
so it'll generate a new password and
then remember that new password and
every time I come back automatically
lock me in as well so save so much time
I'm so used to it that I don't I can't
imagine what it would be like without
having LastPass now I've done reviews on
it with screenshots and workflow that
you guys can check out on youtube
channel but but this one is a lifesaver
I use it all the time huge huge boost
its it's free as well I think there is a
paid program but I'm on the free one it
works wonders for me the second one that
I really use a lot is the email
one here and this is basically allows
you to send an email from any page and
this is tied into gmail so I'm a gmail
user for example if i go to go to my
website and i'm on i click on an article
russell simmons and say ok click on one
of his articles that we have on the site
say i really like this page and i find
that i'm emailing both other people a
lot and also myself i'll send myself an
email as a reminder to do something or
read something later and so I love
having that option built right into the
browser instead of having a copy and
paste it into into a separate email to
say I'm reading this you know say I
really like this quote do a good job of
it and it'll grow on its own and say I
want to send out as an email either to
myself or to a friend I'll just click on
I'll highlight it and click on the email
link and what it will do i'll just pull
it over here it loaded up a separate
email i could type would say to myself
it pulls in the title of the page that
i'm on and it pulls in the quote that i
thought i highlighted as well as the
link and so i guess then send this email
I don't let you want to send us i'll
delete that but it's a fantastic way to
build a quickly send email if you don't
need to highlight something specific you
just want to send the page you just
don't highlight anything and just click
on it and it'll load that fresh email
for you let me pull it into the screen
so you guys can see it here and it'll
just say the title of the page is a
subject line and the URL and so you can
just send that off again i use a lot to
send emails to myself or to friends the
other thing that I really like here from
these ones is the buffer app and buffer
allows you to schedule posts that go to
your Twitter account or to your Facebook
page I use it for Twitter so if I wanted
to send a tweet out instead of copying
pasting it going to Twitter loading it
up clicking
you know the new tweet I can just
highlight this click on my buffer up
here and it's going to log me into
buffer taking a little bit of time so
you can see I've only connected my
Twitter account here but you can also
connect more if you want it'll pull in
the quote and it'll it'll shorten the
link and then I can either share now or
add it to my buffer what will be delayed
and send out at whatever time I want in
the future and so that's another great
way to send out tweets if there's
something on the page that you really
want to share you just highlight it
it'll take that jump and then I can
always add my text you know love this
quote of this boat and send it off so I
won't actually send this but it's great
to have it all within the browser
instead of having to go to separate
tools to do it the other ones that I use
are not consistent so those ones i'll
use a lot the other ones will be on an
as-needed basis so a lot of these are
SEO type of tools so sometimes I'll be
in heavy SEO mode and get all these
tools and use them and then a lot of
times I don't have a use for it so this
one is pretty cool it's just your site
status and it'll it'll give you a
high-level overview of what your Alexa
ranking is and what your page rank is
for every page that you're on so you can
see this one is you know 12,000 that's
for my whole site and this specific page
has a pagerank of one you can go check
out link so who is availability and so
this all sometimes use when i'm looking
at partner websites that somebody emails
me and wants to partner up I'll just
want to take a look at how authoritative
they are you know do they have a decent
website do they have a good Alexa
ranking do they have some page rank if
we go to the home page you'll see that
the Alexa ranking doesn't change what
the page rank does so this is paid drank
hot it's a quick way to be able to look
at any website and then drill down on
more details if you want so that's
that's called SEO status there's also
the one that comes from Alexa itself so
this just shows the Alexa
tool and if you want you click on it and
it'll pop up more details all from Alexa
and this one is another SEO tool SEO
site tools again which will tell you
about the page rank and then also more
details about some of the websites if
you want if you want to dig that deep
this one is cool when you're designing
your website basically since I always
use Chrome I I'm used to using chrome
and that's my kind of day to day browser
but most people still use internet
explorer or at least a lot of people do
so you want to know that your website is
going to look good in internet explorer
so whenever we're designing the website
or making changes or doing a new landing
page or any of those things well this is
a useful tool instead of having to load
Internet Explorer every time you just
click on this and it'll load your page
as you would see it internet explorer so
you can see if there's any design things
that are off and then this one is why
stamp and what this basically does is
edit your signature in gmail and so if
you use gmail you want to have a
signature that pulls in your most recent
tweet or your most recent YouTube video
or your most recent facebook post it
does that automatically for you so I can
click that and I'll edit my signature
for Gmail and those are the basic ones
that I use when I'm here at the options
I have some others that i would use at
home but these are my main ones again
the most important ones for me would be
the last pass and then the gmail and
then probably the buffer and then maybe
you know the the SEO status those i use
almost every day or every day in case of
LastPass in gmail and the other ones I
use more for SEO design when we have
projects or when I'm working on on
something thats related to to SEO so
hopefully that helps make sure the
question a little peak I guess inside my
world and what I'm doing with my browser
for those of you watching if you liked
the video please give it a thumbs up
below makes you want to do more for you
and if you have a comment about this
video I'd love to see it if you want to
leave it in the comment section below of
a question for your own business I'd
love to try to answer for you so thank
you and I'll see you on the next episode
you
you